الفنان احمد فهيم اللي في تاريخه مجموعه
من الاعمال الدراميه المهمه اللي تالق
فيها وعملت صدى كبير هذه السنه اسمه متصدر
الاخبار والعناوين اللي عنوانها العريض
كنت فيني راجل احمد بيشارك في هذا الموسم
الرمضاني بعملين جعفر العمده وعمله نادره
فهو في مسلسل جعفر العمده بياخد دور سيد
اخو جعفر العمده ومن اول ما بدا المسلسل
اللي مكسر الدنيا وعامل ضجه كبيره ومتصدر
قائمه اكثر الاعمال مشاهده والناس بتقول
لاحمد فهيم كنت فين ايش الابداع وايش
التالق فيه الدور اللي متقمصه بكل شيء
سواء حركات مشاعر احاسيس اداء لغه جسد
يعني دور متكامل في كل شيء
احمد صحيح مكسر الدنيا في الدور ولكن من
حلقتين تماما منكسر الدنيا اكثر في
المشاهد خطفت قلوب الناس ومتابعي المسلسل
وهو المشهد اللي شاف فيه سيد مراتو داد
وهي بتتزوج من شوقي فتح الله من بعد ما
كانت هربت من البيت الناس شافوه في
الحركات والتعابير اللي عملها احمد في
المشهد اتقان لا يمكن وصفه والناس شافت في
احمد فهيم فنان مبدعه ومتقمص الدور وعايشه
بكل تفاصيله والحركه وحركات والكل كان
بيشيد باداءه وانه هذا الدور ما كان احد
راح يقدر يعمله بهذا التالق غير هو
ومعنا من القاهره النجم احمد فهيم اهلا
فيك معنا يا احمد وانا طبعا يعني ببارك لك
على هذا النجاح الكبير ويعني شخصيه سيد في
جعفر العمده جننت الناس خصوصا في الاحداث
الاخيره اللي صارت خصوصا بعد ما وداد راحت
تزوجت يعني حالها
بس قبل ما نبدا يا احمد بدي اوريك عينه من
ردود فعل الناس
[موسيقى]
احنا مش
انتوا ليه خايفين احنا مش هنحل هنخيطكم
[موسيقى]
يلا بينا اهو بدا العرض
ولا اجيب احمد مكاوي ولا اجيب مين بالضبط
في الشارع
[موسيقى]
الله يكسبك
بالسلاح جايين
انتوا ليه خايفين احنا مش هنهلها هنخيط
[موسيقى]
هيتنطط على الارض مش
مش هسيبك لوحدك احنا رايحين ناخد حق سيد
عقبال ما تيجي الرجاله كلها ورجعت الميدان
واقفه يا عم
احمد ايش رايك في ردود الفعل هذه
والله والله كل سنه وحضراتكم طيبين
وقناه العربيه طيبه ومشاهدين قناه العربيه
في الوطن العربي طيبين
مبسوط جدا ان مع حضرتك وليا الشرف ومتشكر
جدا
للدعوه الكريمه دي والله مبسوط جدا باللي
بيحصل ده يعني
وانبساطي جاي من ان الناس فرحانه يعني
الناس متفاعله مع الحدث الناس حاسه ان هم
ممكن يروحوا ويدافعوا عني ممكن ياخدولي
حقي يعني الناس الناس عايشه الحكايه معانا
مع الاحداث ومع المسلسل وهو ده الهدف من
من الحكايه اصلا ومن الشغل ان احنا نحس ان
الجمهور متوحد مع شخصياتنا وقدرنا يعني
يعني يا رب نكون صديقين وقدرنا ونقدر نكون
وصلنا للجمهور المشاعرنا الحقيقيه اللي
كانت جوه الشغل يعني اول شيء صراحه اليوم
يعني واحنا كلنا متابعين للعمل ويعني
فعليا مشهد الفرح ومشهد الخناقه والكلام
ده كله فعليا نحن كلنا كنا حابين نساعدك
يا سيد بسمه مش الحال اوكي طيب ولكن الان
ايش يعني يعني لما نقول هذا المشهد اللي
صار
اداءك في هذا المشهد الكل تكلم على هذا
الموضوع انه اداءك انت تحديدا كانك واحد
جمعت خبرات السنين عشان تطلع بدال مشهد
الحمد لله
الفضل يرجع الاول الحمد لله بشكر ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى على
المنحه للدائري في الشغل ان انا اعمل
المشهد بالشكل ده وبشكر بعد ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى الفضل يرجع للاستاذ محمد سامي طبعا
الفضل يرجع له بعد ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
وبتوجيهاته بنصايحه وبارشاده ليا ان
المشهد يطلع بالشكل ده الحمد لله
المشهد انا كنت صادق فيه قوي مع نفسي وكنت
عايز اوصل مشاعر والحمد لله يا رب تكون
وصلت للجمهور حطيت نفسي فعلا مكان سيد لو
فعلا مراته عملت كده هيبقى رد فعلي ايه
فاللي طلع ده مش مش ما كانش مترتب ولا كان
ولا كان يعني ما كانش بالورقه والقلم يعني
هو طلع كده لوحده همم نظرته لها من من
الشباك ومن البلكونه ونزوله الشارع
واخرجوا من الباب بلهفه هو مش فاهم حاجه
هو مش مش هو في اللحظه دي كان في عالم
ثاني غير العالم حتى مشيته لما راح لها
لحد ما راح عند الكوشه ماشي حركه ايديه
الحمد لله الحاجات دي كلها ما كانتش
مترتبه دي بتبقى منحه ربانيه كده الحمد
لله ان هي بشكر ربنا سبحانه وتعالى طبعا
وب الاستاذ محمد سامي انه اتاح للفرصه
وبشكر زمايلي كلهم اللي كانوا على قدر من
المسؤوليه وان هم وقفوا جنبي ان انا اعمل
مشهد بالشكل ده
ويا رب النتيجه تكون على قد المجهود ونكون
قدرنا نوصل لجمهور شغل كويس يبسطهم في شهر
رمضان
الناس لا مبسوطه ومتفاعله بس انا سمعت
كمان انك انت بتنزل بتتفرج في القهاوي وفي
الشوارع على الناس وهم بيتفرجوا على
المسلسل صحيح
والله مش بشكل يعني
كبير يعني انا في يوم من الايام رحت فطرت
في مكان
قدامه قهوه القهوه بيبقى ناس بعد الفطار
قاعدين على القهوه بشربوا شاي بيشربوا
قهوه بيلعبوا طاوله وبيتسلوا
فطرت وبعد الفطار وقفت
وقفت في البلكونه علشان اشوف رد الفعل
والحمد لله يعني مش قادر اقول لحضرتك اكن
مثلا نهائي كاس العالم الناس مبسوطه جدا
الناس متفاعله الناس بتشجع كان في مشهد هو
اللي هو كان مشهد
الخناقه فالناس مبسوطه جدا متفاعله معنا
فكنت عايز اشوف رد فعل الشارع لان ده ما
حصلش في البرنس للاسف لان كان في كورونا
ما كانش الناس بتنزل على القهاوي فكنت
حابب اشوف ده جدا في جعفر العمده والحمد
لله يا رب نكون يا رب تعبنا جدا ويا رب
يكون النتيجه على قد مجهود اللي احنا
عملناه
يعني اوصف لي مشاعرك الان تجاه وداد مدى
كرهك لوداد قد ما نحن بنكره وداد
انتم بتقراوا داد انا نسيتها خلاص يعني
انا انا بحاول بحاول اتعافى من سيد لان
سيد كان عامل لي مشكله سيد كان عايش معي
تلات شهور اللي هو وقت التصوير كنت انا
وسيد بس عايشين في بيت لوحدنا انا ما شفتش
اولادي ما شفتش اصدقائي ما خرجتش من البيت
كنت بخرج بس اجيب اكل اجيب حاجه وارجع
تاني عايش في البيت انا وسيد ببص في
المرايه بلاقي سيد بكلم سيد بذاكر وانا
سيد طول الوقت انا مركز كل التركيز ويا رب
الحمد لله يعني النتيجه الحمد لله يعني
طلعت الحمد لله على قد المجهود فبحاول
اتعافى منه
بس انا لما انت لما انعرض عليك الدور احمد
سامي حسيت انه ممكن ينجح هذا النجاح الدور
انا اي
اي شغل مع الاستاذ محمد سامي انا بتوقع له
النجاح من قبل ما ابدا فيه لان عارف هو
متاكد وكل ثقه في الاستاذ محمد سامي وفي
قدراته الفنيه العاليه مخرج كبير ومخرج
عبقري يعني
فالنجاح مع الاستاذ محمد سامي مرادف يعني
النجاح مرادف محمد سامي على طول فطبعا كنت
متوقع طبعا وده اللي خلاني اركز جدا في
الشغل واركز جدا في الشخصيه ان عارف
محمد سامي عفوا انت لانك احمد وهو محمد في
عاد بدخل الخطوط في بعض طبعا محمد سليم
يعني معروف انه هو بينجم الناس معاه بتنجم
حتى اللي هم مش ما بيكونوا مثلا انه مثلا
محمد رمضان كل اللي حوالينه حتى
بينجموا بس انت شخصيا وانت بتقرا كنت
متوقع هذه رده الفعل
كنت متوقع طبعا رده الفعل وكنت عارف ان كل
وكنت عارف المسلسل كله مش شخصيتي بس كل
الشخصيات كانت اركان متكامله
وشخصيات وشخصيات واضحه كلها فكنت متوقع
النجاح طبعا للمسلسل للشخصيات كلها ولكن
بصراحه يعني ما كنتش متوقع ان الناس هتبقى
يعني نجاح كنت متوقعه بس ما كنتش متوقع ان
الناس هتبقى فرحانه يعني الناس فرحانه
عشان انا كويس الناس فرحانه علشان
باقي زمايلي كويسين ففي حاله سعاده عند
الناس هي دي الحمد لله اللي كملت الصوره
النهائيه وبحمد ربي على النجاح ده بتشعر
انه هذا الدور انصاف لك والمسيرتك
باين من دموعي الحقيقيه وباين من احساسي
يا رب يكون بجد واصلكم ولو وصلكم احساسي
يبقى هو ده اللي انا كنت عايز اوصله لان
انا بشتغل كنت حاسس ان الدور ده
عوض ليا بعد صبر كتير يمكن في مشاهد كتير
كنت بعملها وانا بفتكر الايام اللي صعبه
والدنيا والحاجات وخلاص ويلا ووريني بقى
انت جات لك الفرصه هتعملها ازاي
والفضل يرجع للاستاذ محمد سامي بعد ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى انه اتاح لي الفرصه اني
افرد
جناحاتي واعمل اللي انا عايزه في الدور يا
رب اكون قادر قدرت اقدم حاجه تبسط الناس
يعني احنا مدحنا كثير يا احمد خليني اقول
لك شيء جانب انتقاد طيب بس على الجنب كده
يعني بعض الناس بيقولوا انه بالغته في
المسلسل يعني انه ما بيصير هذه الاشياء في
الحقيقه يعني بيروحوا ومراته بتخلعوا وهو
مش عارف انه مراته خلعته سبع شهور ومش
عارفه ايش والكلام ده كله طب كيف بترد على
اللي بيقولوا انه زودتوها وسعتوها شوي
بصي هو الدراما بتسبح بكده الدراما مرايه
الحقيقه الدراما دايما بتسمح بالمبالغه
وبتسمح بالافوار اللي بيقولوا عليها طول
ما انا في حاله نجاح وطول ما المسلسل
والحلقات في حاله تصاعديه المشاهد موافق
على كل حاجه يعني انا طالما نجحت معك وانت
صدقتني انت موافق على كل حاجه
فالدراما بتسمح
بان انا ازود حاجه واعمل حاجه خارج الاطار
الدراما مش محكومه يعني مش حياتنا او مش
الدنيا اللي احنا عايشينها ومش هنقدر
نحددها في مكان الدراما ملهاش اركان عالم
واسع نقدر نروح هنا ونروح هنا ونجوز ده
ونطلق دي من ده والحمد لله يعني الناس
مبسوطه
والاشاده اكتر من النقد يعني الحمد لله
بس سؤال سريه بس هي احمد في كف انت اديته
لزينه وبعدين في محمد رمضان اداك كف
الكفوف دي كانت حقيقيه
كان فيها جزء كبير من الحقيقه وجزء يعني
كانت على على على نصين زي ما بيقولوا
الحرفيه اللي عند الاستاذ محمد سامي
بيخلينا نضرب يعني هو بيعمل لنا مره
واتنين وتلاته بحيث ان الالم يطلع بالضبط
لكنه يعني حقيقي فعلا والحمد لله باين جدا
في المشاهد الناس كلها بتتكلم على الاكشن
بتاع يعني الاقلام كلها حقيقيه جدا مش
الالم بتاعي بس ولا القلم الاستاذ محمد
رمضان قلم كارم لاخته ودلال كان حقيقي جدا
فكل ففي حرفيه عاليه جدا في الاداء بتوضح
قد ايه حتى لو القلم مش حقيقي هو وصل
للمشاهد انه حقيقي وانا عجبتني فكره
التمثيل من ده الموضوع انه ممكن الواحد
يفضل كده يضرب اقلام في الناس وكده طيب
احمد خليك معانا لانه ما ينفع كمان ما
نتكلم عن عملك الثاني اللي انت حتى طالع
لنا اليوم في
الازياء حقته اللي هو عمله نادره واللي
انت طبعا طالع معانا من موقع التصوير
وطبعا زي ما ذكرت مشاهدينا برضه بلبس
التصوير في مسلسل عمله نادره انت احمد
فهيم بيلعب دور عطيه اللي بيتصل بانه عاد
عنيد وعصبي ومتعند برايه وخاصه مع اخوه
اللي بيتامر هو وابنه عليه علشان يقعد
مكانه ويصير هو كبير العيله
ونرجع لك يا احمد انتو اليوم اخر يوم
تصوير في عمرنادره
او شخصيتك يعني
النهارده اخر يوم في تصوير المسلسل كله مش
انا بس النهارده اخر يوم في التصوير مسلسل
العمله نادره انا عملت اخر مشهد يعني
بسرعه جدا علشان اجي الحق الهوا خلصوني
حتى اول واحد معي اه والله معي الاستاذ
كمان ابو ريا ومعي الاستاذ هشام عاشور
بسرعه خلصوني بسرعه علشان الحق الهواء مع
حضرتك وجبنا بسرعه زرعه كده صغيره من بره
مش عارف جبناها منين وعملوا ايه وعشان
نبان ان احنا يعني كويس احنا في مكان صعب
جدا كمان احنا في الصحراء عاملين بلد في
الصحراء فحاولنا يعني عجباكم الزرعه دي
حلوه تجنن انت اصلا وجودك كله معانا يا
احمد انت اللي تجنن صراحه يعني سيبك من
الزرعه انت حضورك هو اللي مميز بالنسبه
لنا
يعني
عمله نادره اللي يشوف عمله نادره يقول انه
لا ده مش يعني ابدا سيد اخو جعفر يعني
شخصيه مختلفه تماما هل تقاطع التصوير بينه
وبين بعض شويه او لا هذا خلصت منه بعدين
دخلت الشخصيه الثانيه تماما
والله الحمد لله برضو بفضل ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى قدرت كنت بدات جعفر العمده قبل
عمله نادره وخلصت تقريبا 70% من شغلي في
جعفر العمده قبل ما ابدا كنت بدات عمله
نادره بس كنت لسه يعني ما دخلتش في الغويط
زي ما بيقولوا بعمل يعني بروح يوم وتلاته
لا
بعد ما خلصت جعفر العمده شغلي بقى الكثير
بدا في عمله نادره فقدرت ان انا اوفق بين
هنا وبين هنا فكان في شويه حاجات كده يعني
همم تعارض في المواعيد بس الحمد لله اتحلت
وده اللي اداني مساحه شويه ان اقدر ان
اقدر افصل بين الشخصيتين بين سيد وبين
عطيه الحمد لله قدرت اعمل هنا شخصيه وقدرت
اعمل هنا شخصيه بالتوازي مع بعض الاتنين
كانوا مجنني كنت عايش معاهم زي ما قلت
لحضرتك في بيت واحد انا وهم بس ما بشوفش
حد ما بشوفش اولادي ساعات اكلم عطيه سيد
يرد عليا اضرب عطيه سيد يزعل مني يعني كنت
عايش
يعني بس يعني صحتك العقليه بعدين بس
خايفين عليك يا احمد
لسه بقول لحضرتك انا بحاول اتعافى من سيد
يعني انا عطيه لسه معايا بعد ما اخلص مع
حضرتك هرميه دلوقتي وانا ماشي في الصحراء
موضوع الموضوع صعب جدا على الممثل الموضوع
ان هو
يجسد شخصيه ده او اتنين كمان مع بعض
ولو كمان لو عايز يتقنهم قوي ويعيش معهم
الموضوع كان صعب جدا واعتقد ان هي مدارس
يعني في مدرسه اللي هي مدرسه الاستاذ احمد
زكي مدرسه
رحمه الله عليه مدرسه الاستاذ خالد صالح
رحمه الله عليه مدرسه ناس كتير من
الاساتذه الافاضل الكبار المدرسه دي انا
بحبها مدرسه التقمص وانا بحب اعيش الشخصيه
واعيش معاها واخرج من ذاتي اروح لسيد
واروح لعطيه وبعدين ارميهم في الشارع بعد
ما اخلص وارجع ثاني لحياتي الاجتماعيه ده
بياثر عليا طبعا بس هي دي المتعه في
الشغلانه في الاخر فرحه الجمهور ورضا
الجمهور عني هو اللي بيخلي اي مجهود
يتلاشى يعني طب انت يعني طبعا ذكرت نجمان
يعني كبار جدا يعني الراحل احمد زكي الله
يرحمه وطبع ا الراحل خالد صالح طبعا
يمكن اللي الناس ما تعرفوا انه خالد صالح
هو خالك اخو والدتك
مظبوط يا فندم المرحوم الفنان خالد صالح
خالد ففي ناس كثير لما عرفت هذه المعلومه
بداوا يحطوا الشبه ويحطوا الشبه بزياده
وياخدوا صور ويقارنوا على التعبيرات وكده
خلينا الان شايفين احنا على الشاشه يعني
لما بتحط الصور بدي الطريقه بيتضح الشبه
بشكل كبير جدا ايش تاثرت فيه يا احمد
بصي انا اتعلمت اصلا الحكايه من خلال
المرحوم خالد صالح حبيت الموضوع من خلال
مرحوم خالد صالح اتعلمت الحكايه كلها من
اولها لاخرها
هو كان قدوتي في الشغلانه وفي الحياه
عموما يعني التصرفاتي
علاقتي بالناس علاقتي بالاخرين
اتعلمت منه المهنه طول الوقت كان بيرشدني
وكان
بينصحني مابخلش علي باي معلومه ماشي
بنصايحه لحد دلوقتي كان دائما يقول لي ما
تعملش حاجه انت مش قدها ما تعملش لقاء
صحفي وانت لقاء تليفزيوني وانت لسه ما حدش
يعرفك ما تقبلش دور كبير وانت لسه مش قده
ويمكن ده اللي اخرني شويه بس الحمد لله
يعني كانت نصائح مهمه جدا
اخيرا بقى يعني لو فيا حاجه حلوه تبقى من
المرحوم خالي الفنان خالد صالح رحمه الله
عليه الله يرحمه وطبعا العمر لك ان شاء
الله والمزيد من النجاح والنجوميه يا احمد
احنا بنشكرك على وجودك معنا اليوم منور
منور منور هذا الرمضان يعني فعلا
رائع كان هذا المسلسلين صراحه العملين
شكرا لك كان معنا من القاهره النجم احمد
شاهين شكرا لك